bah bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille viviane la lande de la
chaîne syllabus et récemment docteur les
citations aujourd'hui merci merci
bonjour merci de me recevoir dans son
podcast vidéo avec comment est-ce que tu
l'appelles oui tous avaient donc qui
convient à personne qui écoute
est ce que tu vas commencer par la part
de présenter et prend un peu ton
parcours notamment scolaire et
professionnelle ok alors donc moi je
suis française je suis né en france et
ça fait plus de plus ça fait dix ans que
je suis au québec maintenant d'où
peut-être le petit mélange d'accent mon
parcours scolaire ça a été j'ai commencé
avec une maternelle général
généraliste jusqu'à jusqu'au lycée donc
au lycée j'ai fait un bac s un super
bien parce qu'on m'a refusé l'aspect
fini mais je voulais aller inspecter
izik et après j'ai fait un deug donc
l'équivalent de l2 un physique
fondamentale c'était la dernière année
où il délivre l automne
après je suis rentré un école
d'ingénieur en mécanique et conception
et puis après j'ai fait mon stage de fin
d'études à montréal dans un laboratoire
de recherche
j'ai tellement adoré ce que je faisais
au laboratoire que je suis resté en
maîtrisent donc la maîtrise recherche
maîtrise recherche c'est c'est un
programme qui n'existe pas en france
c'est un petit peu l'équivalent d'un
doctorat mais en beaucoup plus court en
terme de contenu c'est vraiment de la
recherche
c'est pas un 6 mois de stage comme les
masters qui inquiète en europe et après
je suis allé travailler comme une grande
personne dans une entreprise qui fait
des satellites des antennes de
satellites pardon après ça j'ai détesté
mon expérience donc je suis revenu à
l'université j'ai travaillé en tant
qu'associé de recherche dans le domaine
minier et après j'ai j'ai trouvé mon
doctorat donc en biomécanique de la
colonne vertébrale que je vienne donc de
terminer donc ça c'est pour tout le
parcours professionnels scientifiques
pour le parcours plus de vulgarisation
j'ai commencéà vulgarisation en fait
quand je suis arrivé au québec n'ont
qu'en 2009 et que j'ai découvert aussi
le monde de la recherche
je sais pas si c'est le québec où le
monde de la recherche qui m'a qui m'a
donné envie de communiquer mais j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait vraiment une
effervescence que je que je connaissais
pas en france et ou du moins dans le
monde pas de la recherche et donc ça va
j'ai commencé avec un blog donc de 2010
à 2011 2013 quelque chose comme ça et
après je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais même moi je lisais plus les
blogs donc savait pas trop de sens
continue à faire un blog donc je suis
passé au format vidéo parce que c'est ça
que je consommais et puis ma g a pris un
petit à petit en faire et donc aussi
dans la même période que j'ai commencé
les vidéos j'ai commencé à travailler à
la télé donc il ya cinq ans et demi
maintenant et je fais la radio depuis
cette année depuis septembre 2010 ok
voilà super merci pour ça quand tu étais
intéressé aux sciences à la base
séparation ouais je pense que oui c'est
je sais pas trop d'où ça vient gdg des
parents qui sont plutôt du côté
littéraire si on essaie de catégoriser
les genres littéraires scientifiques
sont plutôt de ce côté là
mais ils sont toujours une certaine
curiosité scientifique je pense et c'est
ça qui a dû dû m'inspirer vert vers la
science je me souviens j'avais un livre
avec des tas d'expériences scientifiques
quand j'étais petit puis je faisais ça
j'avais mes parents avaient un ami aussi
qui était un passionné d'astronomie
donc c'est lui qui m'avait fait
découvrir ce qu'était un trou noir et
j'ai fait mon tpe de terminale sur les
trous noirs justement parce qu'il
m'avait parlé et trop noir j'avais
trouvé ça fascinant et donc certainement
une combinaison de touches pense que je
trouve ça cool aussi à la télé quand je
voyais des des scientifiques devant un
tableau qui était en train de rédiger
des formules mathématiques et ça m'a
l'air d'être un banquet du mystérieux et
je voulais apprendre un petit peu ce
langage la cua et donc tu as commencé
des études en physique lice à 21 ans de
guerre
oui c'est ça et après tu t'es donc t'as
pas aimer ton expérience travailler sur
les satellites
qu'est ce que c'est non mais c'est plus
c'est plus compliqué que ça c'est il ya
beaucoup de choses déjà il fallait
pointer et moi ça pointe et j'ai
beaucoup de difficulté avec ça j'ai
l'impression d'être fleet et je me sens
pas bien quand je dois pointer j'avais
beaucoup de ces essais des raisons
édicules mais j'avais beaucoup de deux
voitures à faire pour y aller et c'est
quelque chose qui pèse énormément sur le
sur le moral et puis aussi au niveau du
travail
disons que c'était pas compensé par le
côté intéressant du travail
donc bon je devais remplir un fichier
excel qui recensait toutes les
tous les poids de toutes les pièces de
tous les précédents trentaine de
satellites pour voir
je suis plus pour optimiser quel était
le la masse par n'ont pas le poids
la masse de chacun des 10 items bon peu
après j'ai travaillé en r&d aussi dans
ce truc là donc le département r&d était
composée du boss et deux mois n'arrive
pas grand monde
et puis il fallait un design et un un
truc qui est la première spécification
la première ligne du cahier des charges
c'est il fallait pas que ça change ce
qui avait été déjà fait ou ce qui est
très frustrant quand on donne un mandat
ou c'est finalement ça devienne la
politique de devoir design est quelque
chose de nouveau mais en fait non tu
dois design est toujours la même chose
parce que bayal et c'est l'aérospatiale
là c'est ça ou ça c'est difficile de les
faire bouger conc'air donc c'était fou
de plus de frustration qu'autre chose et
je suis parti mais que ça c'était après
sa maîtrise et sa après ma maîtrise
grâce à la maîtrise était en 2012 alors
le oui c'est ça le diplôme est un génie
biomédical pour ma maîtrise et génie
mécanique pour mon doctorat mais pour
mon doctorat ça aurait pu autant être
génie mécanique que génie biomédical
l'epr doctorat c'est la suite de ta
maîtrise absolument la maîtrise c'était
sûr je design et un canadien un embout
de cathéters donc les cathéters c'est
les tubes en plastique qu'on met dans
les vaisseaux sanguins et donc je design
et un embout qui allait au bout de ça et
qu'ils pouvaient être guidé en trois
dimensions grâce à une irm donc les
appareils d'imagerie qu'on a en hôpital
et donc on arrivait à contrôler le set
en boule à magnetic man avec un appareil
d'imagerie et mon doctorat c'était sûr
design et un nouvel implant de
correction la scoliose donc les
déformations la colonne vertébrale des
enfants et c'était de design et une
nouvelle façon une nouvelle approche de
de la corriger ok c'est facile de faire
ce va et vient entre académies
moi j'ai c'est moi c'est ça que j'aime
c'est donc je suis passé de d'apprendre
l'irm après je suis allé dans les
satellites
après je suis allé en génie minier
parfois pourquoi pas et après bien
mécanique de la colonne vertébrale moi
je trouve ça je trouve ça fascinant
c'est un peu mon profil d'être
pluridisciplinaire
donc ouais ça me convient bien et du
coup c'est aussi pour ça que tu aimes la
vulgarisation imagine je pense que ça je
pense que ça aide c'est c'est sûr que
quand on est quand on a la curiosité
facile je pense que la vulgarisation
c'est quand même un bonbon échappatoire
parce que parce qu'on parle à des gens
fascinants en fait est que et qui nous
apprennent plein de choses donc c'est
super intéressant et donc fait pas bien
aimé ta vie de chercher des eaux plus
grand bien mais faire la recherche
j'ai adoré ma vie d'un maîtriserait un
maîtrise c'est là que j'ai découvert la
recherche c'est mon projet de maîtrise
c'était mon petit bébé âgé j'ai adoré
c'est pour ça que j'ai continué à
rechercher c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
j'aime la recherche donc gg
j'ai vraiment j'ai des étoiles dans les
yeux quand je parle de ce projet de
maîtrise
ça a été vraiment de deux années
extrêmement formatrice que je ne le
changerai pour rien au monde
mon doctorat c'était un plus un travail
que j'ai fait mais j'ai fait mon travail
il y avait beaucoup de frustration qui
était qui était lié à des des choses qui
sont pas très intéressante qui sont pas
scientifiques en fait est donc bon
c'était si c'était un travail après je
suis content du résultat mais mais
disons que l'aspect vraiment ce que je
considère comme étant de la recherche et
l'excitation de la recherche des
vraiment vécu plus en maîtrise que l'on
fait c'est quoi du coup c'est cette
extension de recherche
quels sont les particules à basse et
quand on maîtrise moi quand je suis
arrivé je connaissais absolument rien à
la recherche donc j'avais même pas
vraiment conscience de comment on
faisait une expérience en fait je
j'en savais trop rien je savais pas
comment analyser les résultats je savais
pas comment présenter ses travaux dans
un article donc en fait chaque jour
était une nouvelle nouvel apprentissage
donc il ya une fois ça faisait six mois
que j'étais dans laboratoire sur mon
projet je venais de finir mon stage et
j'allais commencer ma maîtrise il ya
moins directeur qui m'appelle dans son
bureau qui me dit ah
dans quinze jours il ya une deadline il
ya une date limite pour déposer un
article de conférences donc dans mon
domaine des articles de conférences je
sais que c'est pas partout pareil
mais c'était ainsi page de résultats à
fournir sur un sujet et il m'a dit ah tu
devrais travailler sur un petit robot
qui nage dans l'irm et ça c'est pas du
tout mais alors du tout mon sujet on
était à des années lumière de mon sujet
il m'a dit tu as 15 jours pour faire ça
et ça ça a été les quinze jours les plus
formateur parce que je suis sorti de
cette de cette réunion
complètement déboussolé à dire mais
c'est pas mon projet qu'est ce que je
fais je sais pas écrire un article j'ai
jamais conduit une expérience qui qui
amène à des résultats fiables comment
fait il ya un post doctorants qui est
maintenant un professeur à polytechnique
qui qui m'a pris sous son aile et qui
m'a qui m'a expliqué un petit peu toutes
les étapes et en quinze jours j'ai en a
fait une expérience on analyse les
résultats
il m'a expliqué ce que l'intérêt de
d'analyser les résultats de façon à
dimensionnelle donc de vraiment de ne
plus utiliser les unités dans son danser
dans ses résultats mais plus de voir des
ratios en fait et ça va plus ça a plus
d'intérêt dans ce qu'on faisait en tout
cas et
non il m'a appris ça on a écrit un
article un simple il est venu ici à 6
avec moi mon bureau à m'expliquer tu
peux pas mettre comme on apprend tout le
temps en france quand on fait de
l'anglais et hindi des rêveurs des 1 28
ans voilà plein de key words d'un ton
article et puis m'a dit non tu fais pas
ça tu fais pas ça tu fais pas ça tout
expliqué dans quinze jours j'ai eu un
espèce de training de recherche qui
était mais est ce que ce genre à la
découverte de ces méthodes qui te ouais
c'est ça c'est sait comment est ce que
je pourrais dire ça ouais je pensais la
découverte des méthodes la découverte en
fait aussi aussi que 1 15 jours on est
parti de zéro et on est arrivé à un
produit final est un produit produit au
sens de la recherche du vrai et donc
cette cette excitation là où il y avait
vraiment quelque chose à la fin c'est si
je pense que c'était une des premières
fois que je que je le vivais quoi parce
que les projets l'école c'est oui mais
ça ça reste ça reste des projets d'école
quelle est l'impression de faire une
avancée
ouais et puis en plus c'est ça a été
d'autant plus gratifiant que ce quinze
jours de travail parce que j'ai pas
travaillé plus que ça sur ce truc là
après je suis allé le présenter en
conférence et on a gagné le prix du
meilleur papier étudierait avec mon tout
premier papier
mon tout premier sujet effet un quinze
jours donc si tu veux c'est d'autant
plus gratifiant quand tu te rends compte
que non seulement tu as appris
énormément de choses mais qu'en plus tu
as bien fait quoi donc c'est c'est eh
c'était super gratifiant très belle
expérience très chouette et du coup t'as
pas voulu rester dans la recherche que
tu penses l'eau en fait c'est que la
réflexion derrière le quand j'ai arrêté
ma quand j'ai fini ma maîtrise c'était
est ce que je dois faire un doctorat ou
est-ce que je vais aller en entreprise
j'étais je pense intimement persuadé que
je voulais aller en recherche mais ce
qu'on entend tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps c'est que le dr à sa ferme
des portes
donc ce que je voulais faire c'est me
dire ok j'essaye au moins l'industrie
avant
de me lancer dans plusieurs années en
recherche pour être sûr que si je
commence un doctorat je le commence pour
les bonnes raisons que tu étais allé
dans l'industrie en tout ils ont quand
même que c'était probable que tu
reviennes honnêtement quand j'ai fini ma
maîtrise j'avais tellement aimé ça que
j'avais pas beaucoup de doutes sur le
fait que la recherche me plairait
j'avais des doutes sur le fait que
l'industrie me plaît ok ok et vous ça a
été assez facile pour toi de retrouver
un privé de doctorat après le projet dr
hawass a été facile en fait je voulais
pas facile je sais pas je voulais être
un biomécanique c'était à mon exigence
et je voulais être à montréal parce que
je voulais pas bougé à ce moment là donc
j'ai commencé à faire la tournée des
profs en biomécanique et puis j'en ai
trouvé un qui m'a proposé un projet et
puis et puis voilà donc ça c'est pas ça
a pas mis beaucoup de temps j'ai pas
j'ai pas souvenir d'avoir un galéré
quoique et est donc d'être a aussi parlé
de la vulgarisation qui est à découvrir
donc ce n'était pas ma maîtrise et ça
pendant la maîtrise je sais pas comment
c'est en france mais au québec qui a des
concours en permanence des concours de
recherche des concours d'affichés des
concours de présentation des concours de
ceux ci des concours de cela et moi je
connaissais pas du tout et puis quand je
connais pas du tout en général je dis
aux défis donc j'ai essayé plein de
concours et je me suis j'ai vraiment
aimé ce sentiment d'être de présenter
mon projet en fait et d'avoir le retour
du regard des gens et de voir dans le
regard des gens que ce que je leur
disais avait un impact bref et je pense
que c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé la
vulgarisation donc c'est grâce au
concours de rechercher ok tu en avais
fait quelques-uns apprête à lancer ton
blog
ouais je pense à ça pas tardé je pense
que j'en ai fait un et j'ai lancé mon
père quelque chose comme ça mais je sais
pas si moi je maintenant je le mets
comme une trajectoire droite des
concours de recherche vers le blog mais
ça il ya certainement eu plein d'autres
belles influences dont j'ai pas
forcément conscience ou dont je me
souviens pas vrai et dans ça fait le jeu
concours mais les 180 secondes
ouais ça c'est c'est plus à la
transition du blog vers la vidéo qu'est
donc là mon blog et ça faisait longtemps
que je l'avais d'ailleurs à ce moment là
et ouais j'ai fait le concours matin 180
secondes donc c'était la preuve
années quand ça existait pas encore en
france exister qu'au québec
donc j'avais plus de chance je sais pas
si je gagnerai encore encore aujourd'hui
il ya quand même beaucoup de 2013
c'était 2012-2013 ville aux dominos et
j'ai fini ma maîtrise en 2012 donc
bientôt donc été la première lauréate la
première ouais là la toute première est
d'ailleurs la seule année où il
autoriser des maîtrises en fait parce
qu'à partir du moment où ils se sont
ouverts en national il pouvait plus
accepter les maîtrises parce qu'une
maîtrise un amérique du nord où une
maîtrise en europe c'est tellement
différent que tu peux pas les mettre sur
un pied sur un pied d'égalité niveau
contenu elle quitte histoire du coup on
s'était rencontrés parce que j'avais
fait le coup était censé être un second
de l'année après s'étaient rencontrés
parce que moi aussi j'étais à l'école
puis think montréal et oui on s'est
rencontré à policer par janie pas à
l'époque est donc toi c'était en 2013 du
coup l'année mais tu avais tu avais
gagné l'étape de pauline folie puis
après j'ai fait la finale et aguerris
pas gagné finale de sucre ou du coup
aussi commencé à travailler à la télé à
la radio
ouais c'est ça donc télé j'ai commencé
quasiment en même temps que ma chaîne
youtube donc il ya plus de 55 ans et
radio c'est beaucoup plus récent radio
où je travaille de façon régulière c'est
depuis septembre dernier
après j'ai fait quelques interventions à
la radio par ci par là mais c'était pas
c'était pas un travail et du coup quand
comment ils te trouvais qu'on se fait
alors comment est ce que la télé sa cp
alors il ya eu plusieurs plusieurs clés
il ya eu une télé teffo sur le c'est
télévision francophone ontarienne où
j'ai fait là je sais plus comment ils
vont trouver donc là j'ai fait 16
capsules web parce que des vidéos au
québec ça s'appelle des capsules
j'ai fait 16 capsules web pour les
enfants pour expliquer des concepts
mathématiques et je suis passé aussi sur
sur leurs émissions ce qui s'appelait
c'est waou
et j'ai aucune idée de comment s'y
retrouver pour ce pour cette émission là
l'émission où je suis actuellement où je
suis depuis plus de cinq ans et elle
s'appelle génial et diffusée sur télé
québec
et là je suis donc c'est un jeu télé où
il ya un animateur qui va animer la
partie je est un autre animateur qui est
dans le lab qui est en fait l'animateur
scientifique qui va expliquer les
concepts et donc ils n'arrêtent pas de
ceux de s'envoyer la balle entre le côté
jeu et le côté lab et moi je suis du
côté lab et on reproduit les expériences
d'anti parle dans le jeu sur le plateau
en live devant public donc moi je fais
partie des personnes qui font les
expériences sur le plateau je ne parle
pas à la télé et ce à la façon dont ils
m'ont trouvé en fait c'est bien du
concours ma thèse en 180 secondes donc
un des profs de politique gérer ma thèse
en 180 secondes
il avait aimé ma prestation il
connaissait le producteur de génial et
il a dit hey hey tu devrais rencontrer
viviane et voilà au dessus bien et que
c'était rémunéré ça ouais le la télé
c'est rémunéré hockey et c'est les
grosses journées assez des journées de
balorre taille a déjà une journée de
répétition qui va durer 4 à 8 heures à 8
heures 8 heures pour deux pour deux
jours de tournage qui suivent donc
disons 4 heures de répétition pour une
journée de tournage la journée de
tournage ces douze heures de travail
dans la journée donc c'est un séchoir et
s'échangeait à ses émissions de co2 pont
c'est des émissions une fois qu'elles
sont diffusées
maintenant ces trente minutes de scènes
quotidiennes il donc maintenant c'est
trente minutes mais on tourne
l'équivalent de une semaine en une
journée de tournage away on contourne 5e
5 émissions par par jour de tournage et
le jour du tournage on a donc on a fait
la répétition une semaine avant qu'ils
aient une répétition dans une salle dans
un studio quelque part quelconque le
jour du tournage on a à nouveau une
répétition mais cette fois ci en
conditions réelles
avec les caméras les cameramans et tout
ça en une pause pour manger et après
c'est avec public live et en enregistre
tout donc c'est pas diffuser live mais
par contre c'est enregistré avec un
public line hockey et c'est donc ça se
fait ça regarde c'est c'est très
aléatoire
moi je fais ça cette année je vais faire
ça tous les mois de mai à janvier ou
février prochain ils sont en pause après
de février à mai mais sinon parce que
maintenant j'ai un j'ai un rôle imprime
un peu plus important où je suis chargé
de guider les étudiants sont donc on est
trois personnes sur le bateau à faire
les expériences et les besoins dont je
suis la chef des trois personnes
donc maintenant je vais être là tous les
quasiment tous les mois après certains
jeudi tous les mois ça veut dire deux
jours par mois donc c'est pas beau hein
c'est minime et mais avant je sais tu es
plus aléatoire c'est difficile de donner
une fréquence parce que la télé c c'est
vraiment pas quelque chose de fixe et
qu'il était bien travailler pour la télé
oui c'est assez sympa il ya moi il ya
plus de découvertes maintenant on fait
donc si tu veux maintenant c'est
vraiment un travail
les gens sont très sympas c'est vraiment
une belle équipe
donc c'est agréable de travailler avec
eux mais je suis plus dans la partie
découverte
d'accord je sais ce que j'ai à faire
donc c'est il ya la partie découvert
stipule et la radio des reversements
mais encore une fois ça dépend de moi
mes disponibilités
eux ils veulent qu'il voudrait que je
passe une à deux fois par mois
et donc j'ai fait à peu près une fois
par mois depuis le début de l'année puis
là je vais passer à deux fois par mois
pour mes jeunes et voilà donc ouais la
radio c'est c'est vraiment un exercice
différent c'est déjà j'écris pas mes
textes comme j'écris mes textes pour les
vidéos je me fais juste des boulettes
pointe juste une liste
et puis je vois bien comment ça va deux
fois l'animateur m'interrompt et il va
me faire partir sur une autre partie de
mon texte que j'avais pas prévu de dire
maintenant
donc c'est beaucoup plus ça ressemble
beaucoup plus à une discussion et c'est
beaucoup plus malléable donc c'est sais
c'est pas trop difficile comme un
exercice ça parce que tu veux tu fais
quoi là dessus
l'intérieur sur un sujet près des
terrains ouais ça donc
soit je donne un sujet que je dis que je
voudrais traités soient eux il m'a
envoyé parce que l'émission s'appelle
moteur de recherche et le principe c'est
que les gens envoient leurs questions
comme si envoyer leurs questions à un
moteur de recherche
et c'est nous qui répondent non ok donc
des fous des fois ils ont ils ont des
questions qui sont auquel je dois
répondre
prochaine question que l'on m'a demandé
de répondre et là j'ai besoin de faire
appel à quelqu'un d'autre c'est c'est
c'est quoi une tonne de co2 et donc ce
qui est une question qui me sort
vraiment de ma zone de confort
donc je vais essayer de trouver des
experts pour m'expliquer parce que je
suis pas sûr de connaître bien la
réponse bref et donc voilà mais jusqu'à
présent les sujets c'était suffisamment
proche de mon domaine d'expertisé pour
que je puisse répondre sans faire sans
faire du journalisme c'est à dire sans
avoir à faire appel à quelqu'un hommes
mais c'est un exercice différent q et
puis goûter au silence il est attaché
youtube cette période ah non je l' ai
même pas mentionné si si si je mens et
oui si j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos
à un 2013 septembre 2013
et tu penses quoi du coup la youtube par
rapport à la radio par rapport à révéler
à c'est tellement différent en fait
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus différent
c'est que sur youtube on a du feedback
on a tout de suite tout de suite le
retour des gens et ce n'est pas
forcément toujours très agréable
d'ailleurs mais on a tous eu le retour
des gens et ça ça fait une énorme
différence parce que là par exemple
hier j'ai publié non comment on
enregistre du moins j'ai publié une
vidéo sur les chiffres et sur pourquoi
est-ce qu'il ya autant d'air dans les
paquets de chips qui est une chronique
que j'avais fait à la radio je n'avais
pas tout à fait le même contenu parce
que on fait pas la même chose à la radio
que en format vidéo donc c'est le
contenu est vraiment différent si vous
écoutez le podcast ou si vous écoutez la
vidéo vous allez apprendre des choses
différentes mais est sûre le sur la
version podcast chez j'ai aucun retour
j'ai aucune idée de ce que les gens ont
pensé de ma chronique gré et là sur la
version vidéo je vois que il a manqué
une phrase essentielle à la vidéo que
j'aurais dû dire parce que moi je
compare le volume
le volume d'un sac de chips avec et sans
air à l'intérieur et les gens une grande
majorité des gens laisse un commentaire
disant si ridicule il suffit de regarder
le poids net de ton paquet de chips pour
savoir combien de chips et ça pour moi
c'était tellement une évidence que je
n'ai pas dit en fait et j'ai juste parlé
du volume parce que ce qui m'intéressait
c'était le volume c'était pas le poids
mais du coup les gens ils sont unis me
gronde entre lille et dans les
commentaires en dix ans c'est ridicule
tu en études pas oublier qu'il faut
juste regarder le poids et donc sur ce
genre de choses sur sur youtube on a
tout de suite là l'information est ce
qu'on a fait de la bonne vulgarisation
ou non parce que tout de suite on sait
quels ont été les les incompréhensions
des gens tandis qu'à la radio si ça se
trouve que j'ai fait exactement la même
erreur qui est de de ne pas prendre de
ne pas dire évidemment on peut regarder
juste poids mais nous on s'intéresse aux
volumes ça prend juste ça de comme
phrase ajouté dans la vidéo pour enlever
80% des commentaires et je sais pas ce
que ça donnait à la radio mais du coup
la radio j'ai aucune connaissance de ça
mais en vidéo là je taperai quelque
chose à pour la vidéo pourquoi les
savates amis a commenté répondu non non
mais je suis pêche
qu'est ce que tu veux faire c'est
franchement c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec ça
c'est un des problèmes de youtube aussi
c'est que c'est difficile et d'i télé
vidéo
ben c'est ça pis tu vois le truc c'est
que c'est ce que j'ai dit est pas faux
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas d'erreur à
corriger mais mais disons que ça aurait
été une meilleure vulgarisation si
j'avais ajouté juste début de phrase est
pas ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya des
gens qui sont restés devant la vidéo en
dix ans en dix ans et qu'est ce qu'elle
est con cette fille elle a oublié de
regarder le poids tu vois donc il ya des
gens qui sont qui sont restés devant
sept minutes de vidéo c'est insultant
quasiment parce que juste j'étais
ridicule avec mon étude j'exagère
insultant à des niveaux d' insulte très
variés j'exagère de toute évidence mais
c'est ça qui est compliqué j'ai pas
vraiment fait d'erreur alors qu'est ce
que c'est juste
j'ai fait une erreur de vulgariser ce
matin je sais pas je sais pas comment
appeler ça je sais pas si c'est un peu
le qualifié d' erreur
et la logique sera pu être un peu mieux
mais c'est ça mais après d'un point de
vue pédagogique quelle vidéo ne peut pas
être mieux
c'est ça offre tout est mieux à chaque
vidéo ou est-ce que tu mais où est-ce
que tu mettes en curseur de et puis je
vais pas tech d'un de ma vidéo pour la
rue au clos des avec une phrase en plus
qu'il faudrait que je retourne qu'il
faudrait que je remonte sa pas de sens
c'est donc non mais si j'ai pas si tu as
une alternative de comment est ce qu'on
fait je j'écoute mais j'ai pas trouvé
mois encore il y avait moi j'étais un
truc à youtube edu kohn à londres avec
le court deux actes philippe disait qui
entend quasiment en train de supplier
les gens de youtube de permettre parce
qu'on a fait à chaque fois congrès au
plo d'une vidéo nous on à nouveau vers l
est du coup ça fout en l'air tous les
u12 précédent puis et puis moi c'est un
peu chiant les abonnés reçoivent à
nouveau la vidéo ça c'est chiant et du
coup ce qu'ils proposaient parce qu'ici
en attendant philippe decorps votre actu
il supplie occasion les gens de youtube
de permettre de frein juste de mettre
une nouvelle édition de la vidéo comme
injuste mise à jour la vidéo donc mort
après la course que zac et comme ils
font en voix off c'est peut-être plus
facile et ça passe de faire ça passait
mieux non voilée ce qu'ils aient cessées
permettre aux utilisateurs enfin on
apprend que youtube saint jean mais de
remplacer la vidéo actuel par une
nouvelle édition par défaut et puis des
gens pourraient quand même accéder à
l'ancienne version que mais moi c'est le
conservera l'url c'est pour moi ce
serait ce serait vraiment primordial
parce que tous les journalistes là
aujourd'hui qui sont des journalistes
web à l'écrit ils peuvent éditer leurs
leurs articles et c'est super important
de pouvoir éditer ses affaires parce que
des fois tu as dis un truc qui est pas
faux mais les gens l'ont tellement mal
compris qu'il faut que tu reformule est
juste une reformulation sa chance a fait
passer ton article 2 un article de merde
à un article de grande qualité
juste parce que tu as changé une phrase
qui est qui qui est le prémice de tout
en fait comme moi avec ma vidéo sur les
chips
c'est le prémice de tous était de dire
ok on s'en fout du poids on regarde que
le volume je n'ai pas dit ce prémices
sahin valley de tout le reste de ma
vidéo j'exagère ces invalides pas tout
le reste de ma vidéo mais pour certaines
personnes ça la n va dit des donc c'est
c'est tellement important de pouvoir
éditer des vidéos mais on peut pas parce
que finalement c'est comme si un peu
l'impact sur la sueur sur les viewers
c'est dur décroche un petit changement
permettra de son lait ça c'est un peu
frustrant de ne pas pouvoir de solutions
voix c'est très frustrant mais ils sont
bien au courant du problème mais je
pense que c'est trop c'est je pense que
les allées les problématiques sont plus
d'ordre légal que d'ordre technique tu
penses
ouais je pense puisque projet technique
ça paraît si simple de permettre que
d'un point de vue technique
ces jeux en tout cas je pense qu'ils
sont suffisamment compétents pour
trouver la solution
d'un point de vue je pense que c'est
plus compliqué de dire vous avez vu
cette vidéo mais elle a changé depuis
que vous l'avez vu donc tu vois quand tu
la référence tu sais plus vraiment ce
que tu partages et puis même tu pourrais
tu es tu pourrais faire une vidéo qui a
un gros impact et puis après chargé le
le contenu et du coup à chaque fois
qu'on fait référence à cette vidéo la
conclusion est complètement différente
bref donc je pense qu'il ya des il ya
des problématiques un peu facile et
parce que par exemple sur arxiv pas mal
de chercher à remettre leurs articles
ils permettent la mise à jour des tic en
gardant la même la même heure à dix oui
moi c'est ça en gardant même url l'url
ce serait bien c'est ce serait d'avoir
plusieurs versions ce serait très très
pertinents moi je l'utiliserai y aurait
eu et il y aurait beaucoup de vidéos où
je viendrai j'ai deux trois trucs le jeu
que vous avez peut-être certaines vidéos
que j'aurais fait une vidéo
disons que si c'était disponible
maintenant j'aurais déjà rey a plaidé
une nouvelle version de ma vidéo avec
les changements les changements que je
voudrais et puis genre se seraient déjà
réole pl odessa mourir a ajouté une
heure de travail et c'est tout je mets
mais bon ça n'existe pas si on peut
parler de ton livre aussi de tout
arrêter a sorti un livre oui à trouver
simplement comme expérience d'écrire un
livre
très difficile c'était super dur elle en
fait déjà j'avais une crainte avant de
commencer à écrire le livre qu'ils
étaient ça fait cinq ans que j'écris
pour de l'oral maintenant il faut que
j'écrive pour de l'écrit et
personnellement moi quand je suis quand
je lis ge
je n'aime pas lire de l'oral j'aime lire
de les crimes et donc malgré mon grand
questionnement c est ce que m'ont écrit
sera suffisamment écrit et non par les
grâces était mon grand questionnement et
après pour les j'ai tout écrit assez
facilement disons toute ma première
version et après on a fait normande
aller-retour avec l'éditrice et qui a
vraiment en fait j'ai pris en compte
absolument tous ces commentaires parce
que je la trouvais vraiment pertinente
déjà émis quelque chose sous le tapis et
soulever le tapis et donc qu'elle allait
tout chercher et je la trouvais très
pertinente donc j'ai vraiment je l'ait
vraiment écouté quand elle m'a dit qu'il
y avait des chapitres ou à s'ennuie un
peu j'ai changé le chapitre au complet
donc donc non j'ai en fait c'était
difficile parce que ça a été intense et
c'était pendant ma dernière année de
thèse donc je faisais une petite
cumulation qui était pas très agréable
c'est pour écrire ce qu'ils font ouais
beaucoup de temps et donc j'étais sans
arrêt en train d'osciller entre
l'écriture pour de l'écrire l'écriture
pour de l'oral l'écriture pour de la
thèse est donc ce mélange de trois types
d'écriture c'était désagréable à voir
tout en même temps et donc ça a été une
expérience facile mais je suis quand
même assez content du résultat quand je
rouvre le livre je réapprends des trucs
parce que j'ai dû mai mais sinon c'est
le résultat est satisfaisant le
le processus a été quand même assez
assez difficile
est-ce que ça a été la même chose pour
toi d'air oui c'est assez
c'était assez c'était très différent
j'ai l'impression pour parce que mon
livre j'ai créé mon livre vraiment comme
une impression que quand j'ai commencé à
écrire un livre
je suis pas n'était pas la même personne
que je suis maintenant j'ai tellement
appris au fur à mesure et pense avoir
beaucoup c'était quasiment de
l'exploration jusqu'à décrire le livre
et ça permet de mettre un peu d s'est
exprimée hésite d idées et puis bon j'ai
énormément des couleurs de choses donc
il fallait réussir à tout combiné et
tout ça c'était long et laborieux mais
il serait très instructif j'ai
énormément appelons écrire mon livre est
ce que toi tu as eu beaucoup de retours
d'éditeurs où il a pris un peu tels
qu'alan manizan j'ai pas eu quasiment
soyons très très peu de retours de
l'éditeur tel quel beau j'ai eu des des
corrections orthographiques prévu est ce
que ton éditeur comprenez ce que tu
écris moi je pense que non
mais du coup j'ai pu échanger avec des
amis que je crois qu il est du coup ce
qui est très intéressant de ce côté là
aussi qu'est ce qu'un exercice assez
différent qui était le choix c'est
intéressant et qui apporte un truc
différent moi c'est mon éditrice elle
comprenait tout ce que j'écris donc déjà
ça aide beaucoup et après juste moment
là finissent finalisation allait partir
en vacances et là je me suis retrouvé
avec d'autres personnes pour parler de
la couverture et du quatrième de
couverture et je me suis heurté à au
fait que io à toutes les illustrations
dans le livre et je me suis heurtée au
fait que
les gens étaient terrorisés à l'idée de
faire une image pour un bouquin
scientifique et donc je leur disais
balade ce serait bien d'avoir une image
qui représente ça et il a et disait non
mais je sais pas ce qu'il faut que
montrer ils fassent de centimètres aux
trois centimètres est ce qu'il faut qui
remonte ce que est donc en fait comme il
lisait pas le texte et qu' il avait
juste un petit croquis de ma main pour
voir à quoi ça ressemble et il faisait
exactement mon croquis donc exactement
ce que j'avais fait moi finalement y
avait aucun intérêt à avoir un
illustrateur et donc ils étaient
terrorisés par le fait que ce soit de la
science et que ils disent des conneries
et finalement je me suis retrouvé à
faire l'essentiel de toutes les images
de mon livre c'est moi qui ai fait et
pour la couverture j'ai pas mal lutté et
c'est moi qui ai trouvé l'image de la
couverture aussi ce que il y avait chez
ceux par ailleurs il y avait une peur de
la science qui était et est dommage que
tu peux présenter un petit peu ton livre
du coup pour éviter un peu oui oui donc
mon livre c'est l'idée de base moi je
voulais qu'ils s'appellent à quoi ça
sert mais elle a été refusée par la
maison d'édition parce qu'il trouvait
que ça faisait un petit peu trop
tutoriel mai mais l'idée c'est vraiment
à quoi ça sert les notions qu'on a
appris au niveau collège donc les
notions de maths physique et chimie donc
par exemple à quoi ça sert juste pas
d'apprendre ce que c'est la pression
à quoi ça sert d'apprendre ce que c'est
le php etc et donc chaque chapitre va
être découpée en deux parties par
exemple pour le ph c'est le premier la
première partie du chapitre ça va être à
quoi ça sert dans la vie quotidienne et
de
la deuxième partie du chapitre ça va
être à quoi ça sert dans les milieux de
la recherche
parce que moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de ces de relier les deux de montrer que
les les notions convoi au collège elles
sont à la fois utilisées dans notre
quotidien et en recherche parce que
c'est pour montrer que la recherche
c'est pas si compliqué que ça en fait
c'est juste qu'on a accumulé énormément
de notions ensemble donc tout ensemble
elles forment un corpus qui semble
complexe mais prises individuellement ce
sont des elles sont toutes basées sur
des choses qu'on a appris au niveau du
collège et donc je voulais vraiment
faire ressortir ça en mettant toujours
ces deux aspects d'un an chacun des
chapitres et puis pour ceux qui se
souviennent plus que c'est le ph ou la
racine carrée ou je ne sais trop quoi il
ya toujours des petits et petits encarts
qui rappelle la partie la partie court
pour rappeler ce que c'est bien mais
c'est vraiment ça se lit vraiment pas
comme un livre de course est vraiment un
niveau de vulgarisation et il ya juste
un tout petit encadré a sauté si on
connaît déjà le sujet pour 6 pour si
jamais un sou semaine puisque c'était
trop cool j'en profite aussi pour
demander quand est ce que tu décris est
la chaîne youtube
en général je laisse les gens faire
c'est compliqué parce que j'ai beaucoup
de mal à décrire ma chaîne youtube
la définition la plus honnête et
réaliste mais qui reste un peu vague
c'est que on parle de sujets
scientifiques qui m'intéresse ça reste
ça reste très vague dans la réalité des
faits on est plus souvent sur de la
physique mécanique
je parle quasiment jamais de chimie
quasiment jamais de maths
rarement de bio et donc on est plus
souvent physiques mécaniques et souvent
physiques du quotidien aussi j'aime
beaucoup le ouverture de paquets traités
le quartier général
les ouvertures de sachets le carton et
ouais c'est ça combien de l'air dans les
villes et dans les chips on est on est
vraiment dans la physique du quotidien
et parce que c'est ça moi là en fait
finalement quand je me suis arrêté dans
mes études en physique j'ai pas eu le
temps d'aller dans tout ce qui était
mécanique quantique
tout ce qui était de la haute physique
on va dire et je suis beaucoup beaucoup
moins intéressé peut-être parce que j'ai
jamais suivi de cours dessus mais par
tous et toutes ces choses là parce que
je trouve qu'on les comprend moins bien
moi en tout cas mon échelle à moins et
vulgariser c'est déjà un exercice très
difficile alors vulgariser un sujet
qu'on ne maîtrise pas enfin de là on
part dans des niveaux de difficultés
incroyables et donc selon moi je trouve
ça déjà suffisamment difficile de
vulgariser pour m'arrêter aux choses que
je sais quoi que je maîtrise des
jeanneret et même quand on vulgarise les
choses qu'on maîtrise déjà on se rend
compte qu'en fait il y avait encore plus
de couches que finalement on maîtrisait
peut-être pas le sujet tant que ça et
donc on se rend compte que même avec de
la physique de base
on n'a pas une compréhension à 100% de
la mécanique
alors si on s'en va pour vulgariser de
la physique quantique qu' il y en a qui
le font très bien mais c'est juste que
moi je suis je me sens pas à l'aise avec
ça si je m'en vais pour vulgariser de la
physique quantique c'est déjà faut que
j'arrive à la comprendre et à comprendre
un niveau où je me sens suffisamment à
l'aise pour vulgariser et ce niveau où
moi je me sens à l'aise est trop élevé
je peux pas l'atteindre
donc c'est pour ça que quand julie
harris des sujets où je ne suis pas
experte je suis obligé de de parler à
quelqu'un de faire parler cette personne
à ma place parce que je ne sens pas de
le faire quand tu vois j'ai passé ici ce
serait ces voire plus donc là je pense
que c'est assez différent de ce que la
loi la physique un peu plus théorique et
du coup un peu plus
les plus mathématique et du coup il
fallait y penser principe assez simple
alors que tu regardes le des trucs de
physique du quotidien parfois
maintenant je pense à ton d'un épisode
sur les ouvertures facile espace des
phénomènes quand même c'est difficile à
anticiper
c'est surprenant weight se fait un nom
en fait moi je me base sur le fait que
est ce que je suis capable de comprendre
les équations et si je prends les
équations de mécanique quantique
très clairement les équations suis pas
capable de les comprendre les équations
de pour l'ouverture facile je les
comprends jusqu'à un certain point c'est
à dire que au moins les équations de
départ je les comprends et les dernières
équation qui ce qui rentre vraiment dans
le locker le corps du sujet ce dont je
ne parle pas dans la vidéo
celle là je commence à plus les
comprendre mais du coup je vulgarise
jusqu'au niveau où je comprends et pour
moi la compréhension de l'équation est
super importante parce que si je
comprends l équation il ya une bonne
chance que je comprenne correctement le
phénomène peut-être pas dans toute sa
complexité tout ça mais au moins je
comprends son phénomène
donc si l'équation de base la comprends
pas je là je transpire un peu j'ai un
petit peu de mal à prendre le sujet à
choisir de ce sujet là pour le
vulgariser tout seul ça veut dire que je
vais avoir besoin d'un expert avec moi
je suis chose intéressante que ce que tu
parce que le souhait du jeune fille sur
un graphique c'est aussi cette règle
c'est de moins et parce que si on ne
part pas des équations
c'est tellement facile de faire un
contresens exactement
et puis après il y en a pas toujours des
équations aussi c'est compliqué tu vas
pour la vidéo c'est donc sur les
chiffres je reviens sur elle parce que
je les ai publiées hier en que c'est
tout frais mais il n'y a pas vraiment
d'équations c'est ses cheveux je plonge
- mais chips dans un bac d'eau puis je
regarde le le volume qui monte mais
c'est je veux dire c'est juste c'est
juste une formule de volume s mais ça
représente pas l'entièreté du phénomène
donc je sais que cette équation de
départ est biaisé lé représente juste
une toute petite partie
donc la grande question c'est ok j'ai
une équation qui représente juste une
toute petite partie du phénomène que je
suis en train d'expliquer
est-ce que je suis pas en train de me
fourvoyer dans l'explication de tout le
phénomène dure
puis bp sur le truculent que l'entv dos
et ses côtés très très expérimentale son
nom des trucs vraiment théoriciens comme
moi ouais c'est ça moi c'est
l'information aux six ans et j'ai fait
ma maîtrise c'était de l'expérimental
mon doctorat c'est l expérimental le
fait aussi d'aller en école d'ingénieur
et pas de pas de poursuivre un recherche
ça fait quand devient beaucoup plus
pratico pratique que théoricien donc gg
pas les bases théoriques pour faire le
centième de ce que tu fais donc aux deux
pratico pratique du coup sur la
quatrième de couverture de son livre la
question après question qu'il veut c'est
à quoi sert la trigonométrie quoi cette
question
oui c'est ok donc je suis allé chercher
mon livre pour répondre aux questions
parce que je me serais déjà je me ne me
souvenais déjà plus de ce que j'avais ce
que j'avais dit dans le livre
donc en fait pour la trigonométrie je
voulais ne pas parler de tout ce qui
brille collage parce que c'est
l'application deux premières en général
c'est qu'on va venir parler de la
surface de son jardin de faire un meuble
et étagères et la ja ja pythagore et
thales way qui reviennent assez assez
facilement et je voulais pas prendre cet
exemple est donc à la place j'ai pris un
autre exemple qui et comment est ce que
on projette les une sphère sur un plein
donc en fait le cas de notre mappemonde
et comment est ce que le fait que le
toutes les maps man 2 qu'on a sont
fausses parce qu'on ne peut pas avoir
une sphère qui est projeté sur un bluff
et donc je parle de la projection c'est
à dire de la transformation d'une
coordonnées qui est sur le globe en une
coordonnée qui est sur un plan en deux
dimensions donc j'utilise finalement la
trigonométrie par le biais des des
projections c'est super chouette
activement pas pensé mais c'est super
chouette que bon point d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs ça m'a fait penser encore une
fois je n'arrête pas d'en parler mais
dans ma vidéo de chips pour pour
calculer mon volume moi j'avais un bac
qui était connu et donc il fallait que
je que je calcule maintenant
mon volume d'eau déplacer mais comme il
est connu qu'il ya une différence de
volume à prendre en compte que j'ai
calculé et du coup j'ai eu besoin de
thales dans cette expérience l'a donc
j'étais contente de me dire avec quel
soin le truc que tu pensais que le plus
génial que tu as appris en écrivant un
divan à bonne question je vais ouvrir
mon livre je pense que c'est tout ce qui
est lié aux ondes
parce que c'était mon sujet préféré
quand j'étais à la fac
j'avais eu un super prof de physique des
ondes qui est décédé d'un cancer
maintenant aujourd'hui mais j'ai
toujours 5 pds 2 cos et je les gardais
longtemps sur ma table de chevet et
j'adorais vraiment vraiment le son cours
de physique des ondes et et depuis je
reste assez fasciné par par toute cette
physique là et donc dans mon livre il ya
une partie sur les ondes sonores et sur
le fait que j'habitais à 10 mètres d'une
voie ferrée pendant longtemps et qu'il
fallait il fallait essayer d'insonoriser
l'endroit où j'habitais pour pour
arriver à dormir malgré le passage des
trains et quand je dis que j'étais à dix
mètres là c'est littéralement dit m
j'étais vraiment soucieux sur la voie
ferrée sous la voie ferrée et est donc
donc il ya toute une partie sur c'est ça
la physique des ondes sonores et il ya
un acousticien que je connais à montréal
je vais aller tourner avec lui
d'ailleurs dans un dans une maison
symphonique et il est il est passionnant
en fait c'est donc le sujet passionnant
et lui aussi il regorge d'informations
donc à chaque fois que je le rencontre
j'apprends des tas de choses sur le sur
le son et je trouve ça voilà moi la
physique des ondes c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un domaine que j'apprécie
beaucoup je pas experte dedans mais je
l'apprécié beaucoup et qu'il ya un truc
en particulier physique disons que c'est
ça c'est le comment est-ce que tu peux
insonorisé ta maison ou plutôt comment
est-ce que tu ne peux pas elles sont
arrivées pour s'isoler de thébaux et des
voisins donc c'est sûr le l'absorption
des ondes dans certains matériaux selon
leur rugosité selon l'ordre
si tu es donc ce genre de choses c'est
le tout premier chapitre de mon livre je
pensais mon chapitre préférant que
j'étais va jeter un oeil
certes il a aussi des regards dans des
conférences
ouais alors je donne des s'est
régulièrement c'est pas régulier genre
tous les mois mais ça arrive de temps en
temps donc je donne une conférence sur
comment une irm fait une image donc
l'appareil d'imagerie un appareil
d'imagerie qu'on a un hôpital et je la
donne essentiellement à l'université du
troisième âge qui est le meilleur public
qu'ils soient donc c'est il ya une
université qui est vraiment pour les
légendes plus de chemin ces 60 ans et
plus et donc je me retrouve avec une
salle avec quoi peut-être 40 personnes
avec des cheveux grisonnants hockey très
très très très grisonnants même et avec
des déambulateurs et tout ça et je leur
explique la physique de l'irm et je vais
jusqu'à expliquer le spin et a expliqué
lin codage deux phases
ce genre de choses et j'y vais très très
doucement et très j'ai des bons retours
avec eux donc c'est cette conférence là
c'est vraiment une conférence que que
j'apprécie beaucoup parce que c'est des
gens qui ont choisi d'être l'arrêt qui
veulent apprendre et donc c'est super
agréable parce que tu sens qu'ils ont
ils ont compris à la fin évidemment ils
pourront pas le troll ressentent qu'ils
te le ressortir mais ils ont compris mon
fil conducteur et c'est tout c'est le
plus important
donc cette conférence là après je donne
aussi des formations youtube parce que
mine de rien comme on n'est pas très
nombreux au québec à faire des vidéos de
vulgarisation scientifique
il ya une demande de hockey mais comment
est ce qu'on fait des valorisations
assez intégrée est donc là pas plus tard
que cette semaine
non la semaine un cahier quelques jours
où j'ai donné une une formation de deux
heures à des gens qui veulent apprendre
à faire de la des vidéos de sciences et
donc j'ai fait ça aussi plusieurs fois
une dernière et l'année d'avant
donc voilà ce jeu ce genre de choc et je
suis perturbé encore pas cette histoire
de l'université du troisième âge c'est
quelque chose à montréal c'est ça c'est
ben non je crois que ça existe dans tout
le québec et six en tout cas moi à
chaque fois je dois prendre la voiture
pour sortir de montréal donc c'est pas
forcément sur l'île de man et d mais non
il y en a vraiment beaucoup qu'il y
avait tout cas pas mal de diversité
comme ça ouais ok et la première fois je
les fais j'ai trouvé ça un petit peu
moyen salle de l'université du troisième
âge et dans un centre funéraire
j'ai trouvé ça je peux vous dire pour
les autres s'est fait bander dans des
bibliothèques salles où je suis allé
mais le premier c'était aussi dans un
salon funéraire
j'ai trouvé ça je trouvais qu'ils
auraient pu choisir notre endroit quel
show ça va rentrer au plus comme il ya
plus c'est trop bien ils sont beaucoup
beaucoup de gens dans le public m'a
écoute à chaque fois j'ai quelque chose
comme 50 personnes dans le publication
donc oui c'est très sympa sommes donc
très contents des sessions de jeu pense
d'eux une douzaine de semaines attendant
ça fait trop si ils ont une session
d'hiver de 12 semaines une session
d'automne de 12 semaines et ils ont un
cours tous les mercredis pendant deux
heures donc avec des conférenciers donc
ces spots très chouette
le but du jeu c'est d'arriver à avoir
personnes qui ne sont pas trop agitée au
bras non il sent pas trop et donc sur
dix sur l'autre truc que tu as dit que
tu donnes des conseils pour en faire des
vidéos youtube c'est quoi les conseils
que tu donnes
alors c'est surtout sur la production en
fait sur l'aspect réalisation de vidéos
je donne pas tendre quand de conseil sur
l'aspect vulgarisation parce que je
considère que la bulgarie l'aspect
vulgarisation c'est exactement les mêmes
problématiques qu'on soit en vidéo à
l'écrit à l'oral en conférence on a on
va avoir exactement les mêmes
problématiques
mais par contre c'est l'aspect vidéo qui
est souvent est compliqué parce que on a
besoin de maîtriser 125 métier pour
arriver à sortir une vidéo
donc l'idée c'est d'arriver à donner les
compétences de base ou du moins les
connaissances de base de chacun des
métiers pour arriver à une production
finale communiqué donc c'est plus de ce
côté là que jeunes des formations du
coup juste pourquoi faire profiter aux
auditeurs qui pourraient être intéressés
par leur sérieux leur chaîne youtube
quels sont les aspects importants de la
production d'une visite et aux
documentations vidéo parce que alors
j'ai j'ai vraiment une mémoire très
mauvaise donc je suis tu je si je suis
pas préparé que j'ai pas mes documents
sous les yeux g j'ai rarement grand
chose à dire donc
l'aspect compétences je parle d'un petit
peu du l'équipement vidéo et à quel
point c'est important ou pas est plutôt
pas d'avoir une belle image en fait
l'investissement financier qu'il faut
faire et selon moi si on a un ordinateur
et un smartphone à 50 dollars donc 30
euros on peut déjà faire des vidéos
suffisamment correct l'idée étant de
s'acheter un micro parce que c'est
vraiment le son qui va être le plus
important
donc ça c'est au niveau du matériel ça
va être vraiment surtout le leçons ça
c'est comme ça aussi que je donne ce
qu'il veut lancer une chaîne youtube
s'est racheté un micro est exactement
après c'est de comprendre sa caméra de
comprendre un petit peu comment
fonctionne la lumière parce que mine de
rien même avec une une mauvaise qualité
d'image ou du moins une moins bonne
qualité d'image parce que maintenant les
les téléphones faut quand même des
belles images
c'est de pas avoir un look trop amateur
et pour pas avoir un look trop amateur
c'est d'avoir une lumière qui est
exposée au bon endroit c'est à dire ne
pas avoir complètement de ne pas être
trop surexposé ou sous-exposés au niveau
du visage si on fait du de la face
caméra donc ça c'est déjà une des choses
ne pas avoir trop d'espacé au dessus de
au dessus de sa tête parce que ça fait
vraiment un look amateurs quand on a
vraiment un gros vide au dessus de sa
tête sur l'image au niveau du cadrage
d'être avec la règle des tiers d'avoir
les yeux un tiers de la hauteur de
l'image ce genre de choses comment s
comment choisir son micro quel micro
choisir où le placer donc voilà ce genre
de formation que jockey et tu fais pas
du goût de d'initiation à la
vulgarisation mais en fait c'est que on
demande beaucoup la demande que j'essaie
vraiment sûr faire des vidéos de
vulgarisation et pour moi la partie
difficile de faire des vidéos de
vulgarisation sait faire des vidéos donc
tandis qu'en fait la vulgarisation
c'est pas que c'est facile c'est pas du
tout ça que je veux dire mais c'est que
si tu veux faire une vidéo de
vulgarisation j'ose espérer que tu
maîtrises déjà la partie vulgarisation
de l est donc que la difficulté
finalement vient du fait de passer au
format vidéo
si on maîtrise pas déjà le format
faire une vidéo de vulgarisation ses
ovaires québécois c'est beaucoup trop
d'efforts pour pour un message qui va
pas passer donc la gestion de la
vulgarisation en fait pour moi elle doit
venir avant la question de comment faire
une vidéo d'accord donc c'est en fait
c'est pour ça que quand on me demande
explique moi comment faire une vidéo de
vulgarisation mais je pars du principe
qu'on sait déjà vulgariser d'accord ce
qui est certainement un principe qui est
pas bon mais je peux pas faire une
cette formation dure deux heures déjà
sur le comment faire une vidéo
ben c'est en prendre un autre deux
heures pour expliquer la vulgarisation
et du coup si tu veux donner des
conseils pour s'initier à la
vulgarisation alors conseil numéro 1
c'est celui quand que vous allez trouver
dès que vous allez taper le mot comment
vulgariser c'est connaître au public je
sais c'est vraiment la première chose à
faire et c'est la même chose en vidéo on
me dira mais en vidéo c'est différent
les gens ils n'ont pas le même temps que
les crips mais c'est c'est exactement la
même chose en fait c'est si on connaît
le public qui a sur youtube on sait
qu'il faut pas utiliser le même temps
que sur lemonde.fr ou du moins c'est
qu'on va rejoindre notre type de
personnes sur youtube parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de public sur youtube mais
messi ont acquis est ce que je
m'adressais moi je veux m'adresser à des
jeunes curieux de science
est ouvert donc ce gens et tout ça ça va
prendre en compte que ben peut-être
qu'il faut que je fasse des références à
la pop culture
peut-être qu'il faut que que je parle de
façon légère savait pas trop avec le
costard cravate devant un tableau parce
que c'est pas cette image que je veux
donner donc en fait c'est à partir du
moment où on sait quelle image nous on
veut donner et à qui on veut parler de
la façon dont on produit sa vidéo va
découler de ça donc la première étape de
vulgarisation c'est connaître son public
donc une voie que tu connais ton public
tu sais comment tu vas devoir aborder
les choses si tu sais que ton public
n'est pas un expert en physique
fondamentale
peut-être qu'il va falloir que tu
définissent ce que c'est la mécanique
quantique
si tu t'adresses à quelqu'un qui est
déjà un expert en mécanique quantique
ben t'as pas besoin de passer par cette
étape de définition là et tout tout
absolument tout va découler de public de
la connaissance du public à qui tu
t'adresses et pour moi c'est vraiment le
conseil numéro un et c'est le conseil
numéro un dont on soupçonne peut-être
pas toutes les ramifications
parce que ainsi connaître mon public au
québec ces deux jeunes donc ébats des
jeunes je vais parler comme ça oui non
maintenant laisser des jeunes qui savent
quoi est ce qu'ils savent ce que c'est
une molécule est ce qu'ils savent ce que
c'est une addition priori oui mais on
sait pas à quel point ce qu'ils sont
jeunes est ce que c'est des jeunes
jeunes ou est ce que c'est des jeunes
moyens jeunes ou est ce que c'est des
jeunes viennent donc la définition de
son de son public ça ne passe pas juste
pas reconnaître la tranche d'âge mais ça
passe aussi par le fait de savoir ce
qu'ils savent ce qui est très difficile
à déterminer
oui et une fois qu'on suppose qu'ils le
savent ça on peut pas il faut il faut
arriver à tourner son discours à partir
de ce point là et c'est pas forcément
facile quand on a plus de connaissances
que le public à qui on s'adresse de se
rendre compte qu'il faut définir tel ou
tel terme et si tu pouvais revenir dans
le passé et donner des conseils à ton
toi qui qui lance sa chaîne youtube
ainsi stress urssaf
non je donnerai pas de conseil à mon
vivant je trouve mon nom je suis content
du parcours
non j'ai en fait ce que je pense que si
aujourd'hui j'ai gelé conseil que je
peux donner je les ai c'est parce que
justement j'ai fait plein d'erreurs et
que je continue d'en faire ma vidéo des
herses d'hier sur les chips grady ce
satané morceau de phrase c'est une
erreur et donc en apprend de ses erreurs
et je pense que en fait à un moment
donné il faut se sortir de tous les
conseils se sortir de tout l'est tous
les cours et juste produire et quand tu
produis quelque chose et que tu te rends
compte avec le feedback des gens que tu
a produit quelque chose qui est pas du
moins où il manque une définition et
minquiers où les gens n'ont pas compris
c'est là que tu apprends c'est là que tu
te rends compte que ça veut dire deux
camps de connaître son public c'est bien
beau de dire il faut que tu connaisses
ton public mais ça ne veut rien dire
tant qu'on s'est pas planté donc en tout
cas moi je suis grand une grande
partisane de l'apprentissage par les
rabbins faisons et du coup quelles sont
les grandes erreurs récurrentes que tu
faisais au que je fais toujours le trou
dans le son c'est parce que je
réfléchisse les grandes erreurs que je
faisais j'ai su depuis que je fais des
vidéos j'ai surtout appris à produire
mes vidéos donc il ya vraiment beaucoup
d'erreurs liées à la vidéo
après à la vulgarisation quelque chose
que comme on reproche beaucoup à l'étape
de relecture du texte c'est que souvent
je ne met pas assez en avant les
résultats
ouais parce que je suis moi je suis très
intéressé par la méthode en fait par le
fait d'arriver au résultat mais les
résultats en eux-mêmes
finalement ça m'intéresse pas tant que
ça allait et donc souvent j'ai ce biais
là qui est que les gens quand ils
viennent regarder une vidéo et viennent
pour avoir la réponse à une question et
si moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
processus est pas la réponse à la
question mais je satisfais pas
l'audience d'appel
donc j'ai il faut que je mette
maintenant j'ai un effort conscient
quand j'écris mes vidéos de hockey il
faut que ma section résultat soit clair
il faut que à la fin on est une réponse
à la question et ça et ça c'est un peu
étrange mais j'ai pas tendance j'ai
tendance à dire oui donc c'était 3% bas
et mais non il faut mettre l'emphase il
faut vraiment dire donc la réponse à la
question c'est pour que les gens ils
servent aux prêts à recevoir la question
la réponse pardon mais si tu dis donc
c'était 3% et donc voila merci d'avoir
regardé la vidéo
les gens ont pas calculé qu'ils ont eu
la réponse donc il faut mettre plus
d'emphase là dessus moi j'ai serré c'est
maintenant c'est que j'ai vraiment
tendance à a pas assez donné la réponse
de façon vraiment très clair c'est à
dire qu'elle y est la réponse mais si tu
la loupe et tu as loupé je trouve ça
intéressant ce que tu es ce que
peut-être en effet j'ai dit en une
phrase ça passe par ailleurs mais à l
inverse se chauffent beaucoup
vulgarisateur donne beaucoup trop
d'importance aux résultats de la science
enfin comment est-ce qu'on a du coup
j'aurais tendance à faire la critique
inverse a pas mal de mes sacs et les a
pressés c'est mon but à moi c'est que
c'est que moi je suis vraiment un
expérimental à la base est la raison
pour laquelle j'aime l'expérimental
c'est pour faire l'expérience
ma partie préférée c'est de faire
l'examen la partie des résultats c'est
comme moi voilà ça fait ça c'est que la
prochaine expérience
donc en fait c'est mon bien moi je
dirais la même chose
victor hissel m'intéresse c'est le
raisonnement les arguments la
démonstration du théorème si ses
intérêts c'est intéressant est ce que tu
fais des relectures de scripts pour
donner pour toi tu es ce que je fait
relire mon script c'est ça que tu veux
dire alors oui tous systématiquement
je fait relire au moins une personne qui
est pas forcément du domaine mais juste
pour qu'ils me disent est ce que ça a du
sens c'est ce qu'on comprend où est ce
que je m'en vais s comprend les tenants
et les aboutissants donc
systématiquement après au niveau des
experts ça va dépendre des vidéos les
vidéos où il ya un expert c'est qui est
présent la caméra ou qui m'a aidé pour
faire le contenu c'est certain qu'ils
aient redit le script si je suis sur un
sujet que je ne maîtrise pas du tout que
ce soit un expert donc oui une relecture
si je suis sur un sujet que je maîtrise
j'ai juste une relecture de bach homme
gisait avec une personne qui va qui va
re lire si ça se tient chronique et qui
tu as eu des problèmes de fiabilité de
ce que tu disais avant de te dire des
erreurs des erreurs
ah ouais tout le temps c'est en fait
c'est après ces il faut faut quantifier
ce qu'on appelle une erreur et à partir
de quand est-ce que c'est considéré
comme une erreur pour moi une erreur est
une erreur est une erreur grave pardon
quand la personne qui a vu la vidéo
ressort avec le message fossé s'il ya
une erreur factuelle qui ne changent pas
le message c'est une erreur toujours
mais c'est une erreur qui est pas si
grave et c'est une erreur que je ne vais
pas chercher à corriger qui ne va pas
justifier un resop lot de la vidéo par
exemple si le message si l'erreur est au
point où ça change les messages ça ça
justifie de tes gars de la vidéo et de
la rue e pl2 et ça j'ai jamais eu de le
changement de messages mais par contre
des erreurs factuelles
oui j'en ai eu j'en ai eu plusieurs
coins j'en ai plusieurs
mais mais rien qui justifie s'il ya une
vidéo que j'étais agent qui est ma
deuxième vidéo de la chaîne 10 à 5 ans
ou un truc sur l'aérodynamique des ailes
d'avion où j'ai dit une connerie au
milieu je sais plus ce que c'était j'ai
dit une connerie et donc celle là
n'existent plus sur machado mai
mais puis à ce moment là de façon
j'avais même pas 100 viewer même si j'ai
pas dû influencer trop cheveux récemment
par participe aussi à la chaîne youtube
de vortex
oui oui nous parler un peu de ce que
c'est ouais alors c'est un projet on a
fait la semaine de tournage à 1
septembre début septembre dernier donc
septembre 2018
et donc c'est un projet que les eaux
avaient lancé en fait de ce que je
comprends c'est arte qui avait contacté
les eaux et 1 lui disant et on fait une
série ensemble et léo a plus ou moins
répondu je préfère qu'on fasse plutôt
une coloc de vulgarisateur plutôt que de
faire une série moi tout seul et donc
c'est un projet qui a mis énormément de
temps à se monter et finalement la
première saison est arrivé donc on était
quatre youtuber donc les eaux de dirty
biology clotilde de passer sauvages les
postes process donc on les appelle un
youtube heures mais ces trois gars et
puis donc moi et on est allé tourner
chez le producteur donc ronan qui est
celui qui fait le netbook est donc
c'était lui qui produisait la vidéo et
on est allé tourner chez lui pendant une
semaine et on avait trois scripts chacun
qu'on a envoyé à arte puis donc c'est
arte qui finance qui qui est producteur
exécutif de cette série et tout est
publié donc sur une chaîne sur une
chaîne tous les mercredis à 18h je crois
quelque chose comme ça et en ce moment
la saison 2 est en production je crois
qu'ils ont déjà tourné ils ont déjà fait
leurs semaines de tournage avec la
saison 2 est donc voilà donc ça avance
bien je crois qu'ils sont quasiment à
5000 abonnés déjà sur le vortex donc
serré c'est plutôt pas mal
c'est un bien bel accueil tu étais pas
bien aimé travailler avec powertex c'est
compliqué de répondre disant que disons
qu'on a essuyé les plâtres mais ton
ça c'est le tournage s'est bien passé je
suis vraiment contente du résultat et
la communication avec arte a été un peu
compliqué j'aurais pas beaucoup plus
donc l'important c'est d'être content du
résultat et et c'est cool parce que le
projet continue et puis je pense que la
saison 2 vraiment ils ont ils ont
vraiment pris en considération tout ce
qui avait bloqué avec nous à la saison
sèche et donc je pense que pour eux ça
s'est vraiment bien passé donc après
c'est juste une affaire d'ajustement on
est avec des gens qui ont l'habitude de
produire de la télé et versus des gens
qui ont l'habitude de travailler tout
seul donc un moment donné faut trouver
un terrain d'entente donc ce terrain
d'entente et nous on a essayé de plâtre
et maintenant je pense qu'ils vont
trouver que je m'inscrirai ils ont ils
arrivent à travailler correctement mais
non pour nous ça a été ça n'a pas été si
facile que ça recule ce n'est le
résultat est bien donc c'est ça qui est
ça qui est important
collaborer avec d'autres institutions
c'est pas toujours facile
non et c'est ça mais je pense que tous
les tous les gens qui s'il ya des gens
qui nous écoutent qui ont déjà travaillé
pour d'autres personnes ils savent ils
savent le genre de problèmes aux
problématiques auxquelles je fais est
donc maintenant tu t'es lancé temps
plein dans la vulgarisation
bah ouais on va essayer ça on va voir on
va voir ce que ça donne pendant quelque
temps puis que je réaliserai dans
quelques mois quoique d'accord quand
même bon courage pour ça oui merci était
pas d'autres projets que t'as pas encore
mentionné en ce moment de vulgarisation
n'ont pas vraiment que j'ai j'ai pas là
je suis pas sur un projet de livre je
suis pas sur un projet de documentaire
je suis pas sur un projet danger pour
l'instant c'est juste ma chaîne ça va
être un petit peu l'objectif
l'idée c'est de la rendre la plus
rentable financièrement le plus
rapidement possible pour essayer de m'en
extraire un peu c'est à dire que
j'aimerais vraiment
avoir pouvoir embaucher une personne qui
fasse toutes les tâches qui me gonfle
dans la partie de production vidéo et
puis me rémunérer un peu quand même pas
y être
donc l'idée c'est vraiment d'arriver à
monter une équipe parce que je
travaillerai pas tout seul toute ma vie
change je peux pas envisager ça donc on
verra si j'arrive à la à la rendre
viable financièrement donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de de mettre un gros coup pour
pour arriver à ça à la rendre viable
pour au moins de trois personnes quoi ce
serait l'idée parce qu'elle est partie
que tu aimes pas dans la production de
vidéos
ouais bah c'est toute la partie déjà
être seul au tournage c'est
insupportable je recommence souvent les
tournages parce que le focus je pensais
qu'il était bon qu'il n'était pas bon
toute la partie pré montage qui a hacké
chiante toute la partie de gestion
gestion de la chaîne tout ce qui est
administratif tout ce qui est réseaux
sociaux tout ce qui est comptabilité
tout ça mais ça me sort par les trônes
et donc donc tout c'est toutes ces
parties là en fait il ya des gens qui
savent très bien le faire et qui saurait
mieux le faire que moi donc je
trouverais ça pertinent qu'il ya des
gens qui le fasse et ma place pour
l'accueil était parce que du coup par le
groupe atv des sections d'enseignement
oui tout à fait j'ai enseigné pendant
trois ans et j'écoute a pas c'est pas un
truc qui te tente annoncée du monde s'y
met pas disons que si j'avais le métier
que je voulais dans la zone jeffrey la
moitié de ma semaine de la recherche et
l'autre moitié de ma semaine de la
vulgarité dieu mais pour moi la
vulgarisation ou l'enseignement cd
domaine tellement proches que c'est soit
l'un soit l'autre
oui parce que j'ai un besoin de de
produire de la science en fait la
vulgarisation produit pas de la science
ont produit juste la cerise sur le
gâteau et moi j'ai quand même un besoin
de produire le gâteau au stylo et donc
donc c'est pour ça que j'aimerais
j'aimerais vraiment me libérer du temps
d'où l'idée de rendre la chaîne rentable
financièrement pour faire vraiment de la
science pour faire vraiment de la
recherche et aimé ça mais pour moi c'est
soit l'enseignement soit vulgarisation
gt soit l'un soit l'autre
ou alors j'arrive à partager mon temps
entre entre vulgarisation et
enseignement mais mais mais pas mais pas
les deux pas les deux en même temps quoi
tout ça fait ça ferait trop parce que du
coup tu comptes faire encore un peu de
recherche
j'aimerais bien mais pas tous est non je
vais d'abord essayer je donne un gros
coup sur la chaîne et si j'arrive à la
rendre finances viable financièrement
j'aimerais bien arrivé à me libérer du
temps grâce à cette viabilité financière
pour faire de la recherche et donc il y
en a qui sont chercheurs à vulgariser
tort soir aux heures perdues tu tu veux
faire un pas vers ce n'est pas cette
honte et pas de continuer la recherche
directement en fait si tu veux j'ai une
chance maintenant de de lancer ma chaîne
à temps plein donc je la prends
maintenant ça veut pas dire que je
retournerai pas en recherche un jour
pourquoi pas d'y aller mais moi j'ai
j'aime toujours à la recherche et et je
crois toujours beaucoup à ce qu'on a
apporté dans le domaine dans le domaine
scientifique donc non moi je sais c'est
vraiment ce qui me botte ce qui me
battre pour moi vraiment la
vulgarisation c'est la cerise sur le
gâteau mais ça prend du gâteau donc
non j'aime beaucoup la production de
gâteaux quand tu vois futur la
vulgarisation
sachant que c'est pas mal évolué au
cours des cinq francophones en
francophonie youtube ouf enfin parole
non en fait je vais répondre
francophonie je sais pas je sais pas je
sais pas je pense qu'il ya je vais
revenir à ça parce que malheureusement
c'est le séminaire de la guerre partout
hein mais ça va dépendre des finances et
donc il ya deux choix soit les gens
acceptent de travailler gratuitement et
dans ce cas là c'est forcément un truc
sur le côté soit il ya des financements
qui se débloquent et les gens deviennent
des professionnelles de la vulgarisation
et j'espère qu'il aura toujours les deux
je pense qu'il y aura toujours les deux
quoi qu'il arrive mais ce cas c'est que
les financements il n'a pas à l'infini
donc ça va ça va resté restreindre pour
moi youtube
c'est une télé mais version version
cheap en fait version pas beaucoup
d'argent et mais par contre on s'enligne
de plus en plus vers la de la production
et les vortex et mine de rien c'est une
production télé tu vois c'est très carré
c'est tout temps le même le même format
c'est tout le temps je veux dire les
plans sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
parce qu'on est dans delà de
l'optimisation en fait donc le contenu
est toujours bon mais on est dans de
l'optimisation de production et donc
plus on s'en va vers quelque chose ou on
veut produire à des à des bas coûts tout
en étant rémunéré ben on s'en va vers
des des productions qui sont beaucoup
plus lisse et beaucoup plus automatisée
et à partir du moment où on a beaucoup
de gens qui travaillent sur un projet on
a aussi un
un lissage de l'information c'est-à-dire
que plus tu as de personnes qui viennent
ajouter leur point de vue sur un texte
plus d'un lissage du texte plus tu vas
avoir un texte qui convient à tout le
monde alors c'est à la fois bien et à la
fois pas bien à la fois bien parce que
tu as plus de considération pour enfin
je veux dire t'as plus d'avis donc
forcément tu vas toucher plus de
personnes parce que tu as tu as eu
différentes visions de la chose mais de
notre côté tu perds un peu ta
particularité ta vision d'auteur et tu
perds un petit peu tata caractéristique
est ce que c'est bien est-ce que c'est
pas bien ça c'est ça dépend du formage
pense mais donc donc je pense qu'on s'en
va vers quelque chose de plus en plus
télé donc de ce qui veut dire ce que
j'appelle de plus en plus délaissés de
plus en plus produit avec de plus en
plus d'argent dedans mais aussi de moins
en moins de gens qui accéda à ce genre
de production là donc
donc voilà puis aussi c'est je veux dire
moi quand j'ai commencé il ya cinq ans
sur youtube si on regarde mes vieilles
vidéos
c'est une catastrophe c'est dégueulasse
la qualité aujourd'hui que quelqu'un qui
commence avec cette qualité là je sais
pas s'ils arrivent à se développer quoi
j'en sais rien peut-être que peut-être
qu'au bout de cinq ans il y arrivera
aussi j'en sais rien mais un jeu
honnêtement moi je consomme du peu du
contenu qui est quand même de qualité en
tant que consommatrice moi de mon côté
et et plus ça avance plus les gens
produisent des choses de qualité avec du
gros matériel
donc ça c'est ça on s'en va vers une
professionnalisation je pense beaucoup
plus je pense que c'est plus dur de
percer cure non j'ai pas forcément plus
dur de percer mais il faut peut-être
avoir plus de compétences dès le départ
et ses compétences vidéo parce que
malheureusement ou heureusement ça
dépend comment on voit les choses mais
tu as beaucoup de vulgarisateur qui sont
très bons en vidéo et mais par contre le
message derrière ils passent jamais mais
par contre c'est joli il ya plein de
choses qui se passe à l'écran mais la
côte et vulgarisation est pas bien et
vous développez tueur est donc tu as
aussi de la mauvaise organisation qui se
fait avec des bonnes productions et donc
ça on est on est on est rapidement
trompé en tant que spectateur se dise la
bonne production c'est que ça doit être
vrai ski raconté
peut-être pas c'est quoi la différence
entre une bonne et une mauvaise
vulgarisation alors déjà là la mauvaise
vulgarisation c'est une vulgarisation
comme je disais tout à l'heure qui
propagent une idée fois cela c'est peu
importe que même même si la personne qui
vulgarise et avait la bonne
la bonne idée de ce qu'il était en train
de vulgariser si le message qu'ils
restent dans la tête des gens est
inverse c'est de la mauvaise
vulgarisation donc c'est ça c'est la
recherche de la vérité quoi à quel point
on est le plus proche de la vérité après
c'est un curseur parce que il ya vérité
vérité
par exemple moi aussi je dis que la
scoliose en clé des formations la
colonne vertébrale ce sur quoi je
travaille et pendant ma thèse c'était si
je dis que c'est une
quand les gens sont penchés sur le côté
si c'est techniquement faux parce que la
vraie définition c'est que c'est une
déformation tridimensionnelle de la
colonne vertébrale
mais si je dis ça en introduction de
vidéos une déformation tridimensionnelle
de colonne vertébrale je suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient grand monde qui sache ce
que ça veut dire
cette déformation 3d de faire fuir les
gens et ça risque de faire fuir les
champs donc donc l'aspect vérité c'est
oui c'est vrai mais et jusque jusqu où
est-ce qu'on accepte d'être fou quoi
parce que j'étais entendit penchée sur
le côté si c'est techniquement faut
c'est scientifiquement faux mais ça
suffit pour la représentation de la
scoliose de de tous les deux tous les
patients quoi donc ou non cuit le pour
moi la bonne vulgarisation si la
vulgarisation qu'ils ne propagent pas
une idée fausse mais qui est deux
malheureusement tout à fait relative à
l'opinion de chacun parce que chacun va
avoir son curseur de vérité à des
endroits différents selon sa propre
expertise
ouais ouais ça serait quoi ta propre
vidéo préférés à deux mois la vidéo sur
le marathon
probablement une des vidéos les moins vu
qu' une vidéo que j'ai fait donc avec
deux personnes qui courent il un
marathon et je les ai suivis à vélo sous
la pluie et angers mesurer leur j'ai
mesuré leur comme en appel sa stride
life leurs foulées ouais j'ai mesuré
leur foulée et g j'ai fait d'autres
mesures et donc j'ai parlé de la science
du marathon derrière ce que c'est le mur
etc
j'avais parlé est ce qu'on va est ce qu
on dépense moins d'énergie qui dépensent
le plus d'énergie entre celui qui est
cours lentement et arrivent plus tard ou
celui qu'ils courent plus vite mais
arrive plus tôt donc j'ai parlé un
chercheur pour ça c'était super
intéressant donc non c'est une vidéo
vraiment et le résultat je l'aimais
beaucoup
donc c'est ma vidéo préférés qu'est ce
qui fait que celle là est très bonne
alors je pense pas qu'elle soit très
bonne en terme de vulgarisation par
exemple le titre est extrêmement mauvais
ça s'appelait la science du marathon je
pense que j'ai changé il ya trois jours
le titre je sais plus quand je
l'appelais maintenant mais je vais vous
courir un marathon
ah ok je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
meilleur tri de titres mais bon j'ai
fait et je sais pas il ya je pense qu'il
y avait un bon choix de musique
étonnamment moi c'est une expérience qui
me parle parce qu'on l'a vécu cette
chose là c'était sur le terrain n'a qu'à
une partie expérimentale ya une partie
où j'ai vraiment appris de l'information
quand moi j'ai appris l'information
c'est que c'est une bonne vidéo pour moi
si j'ai pas appris d'informations c'est
pas une bonne vidéo pour moi c'est une
vidéo que je fais rapidement juste pour
pour produire une vidéo si j'apprends à
me et pour moi c'est vraiment un facteur
important d'apprendre quelque chose
quand je fais quelque chose et je sais
pas c'est un c'est un combo de tout ce à
quoi on puis c'est mes amis qui sont
dans cette vidéo c'est non c'est passé
c'est ses traits c'est très personnel ce
à quoi une vidéo sympa ouais ça c'est
une vidéo que j'ai fait en équipe
possible
ça ça aide beaucoup en équipe c'est à
dire que franck une des personnes qui
courait le marathon c'est une des
personnes avec qui je travaille de temps
en temps pour faire mes vidéos et avec
qui on va vraiment pouvoir réfléchir sur
le sujet on va
à venir réfléchir sur les concepts
scientifiques sur la façon de les
présenter et tout ça est donc moi dès
que je travaille en équipe de manière
générale c'est une vidéo qui va beaucoup
plus me plaire ce j'ai horreur de
travailler seul
mais mais mais en choisissant la
vulgarisation à temps plein à ses
intérêts
mais voilà donc moi c'est ça travailler
l'équipe de l'expérience sur le terrain
avec mes potes une bonne musique on est
forcément on arrive à une vidéo qui me
plaît quand est ce que tu as d'autres
vulgarisateur mois le wiki déjà instauré
un peu triste personnes yatim blé de
capelle acapella mais encore il était
très timide on communique pas trop elle
m'a pas du tout même mais on sait qu'on
existe surtout lui un anglais donc c'est
assez compliqué c'est pas la même chose
qu'eux mais maintenant personne à
montréal mais tu te fais quand même voie
que tu parles soit et amis de tes vidéos
de ta production n'ont certainement que
dirait le contraire et direct mais moi
je trouve gênant je parle je parle avec
des gens qui sont en france
essentiellement donc avec les eaux avec
dave ce genre de personne et les odeurs
tibet dj dave de des tchèques je pense
que ça s'appelle comme ça sa chaîne et
ma nombril aussi donc je discute avec
avec ces personnes là plutôt parce que
parce que mine de rien les
problématiques qu'on a sur youtube si on
n'est pas soi même c'est difficile de
les comprendre mais va expliquer à
quelqu'un dans ton problème de
miniatures bon c'est un peu c'est un peu
c'est un peu difficile je pense que
bonsoir à tous
ces temps ci c'est un peu plus proche de
très proches en tout cas des gens qui
sont très loin géographiquement
ouais c'est ça
sinon passez un souvenir assez différent
comment est ce que tu vois le futur de
l'humanité est ce que tu penses qu'ils
et les choses occupante
oh my tu me sors de ma zone de confort
big time
en fait moi je suis j'ai un un biais qui
est que j'aime être heureuse
ce qui fait que j'ai tout ce qui est
anxiogène
je met des oeillères donc je suis je
volontairement je ne les écoute peu les
nouvelles anxiogène et donc si tu veux
le futur de l'humanité jeu pour moi il
est très positif parce que j'écoute pas
troubler les nouvelles et très
volontairement et il paraît qu'on est
dans un monde qui a jamais été autant en
paix dans l'histoire de l'humanité
en ce moment et les informations quand
on reçoit sont absolument en
contradiction avec sa disons qu'on a le
ressenti on a ressenti complètement
différent et moi donc j'aime j'aime
vivre dans cette petite bulle que je me
suis créé au jeu où je refuse un petit
peu tous les to les un flux négatif
donc je prends vraiment des bribes
d'information où je sais qu'il ya eu un
attentat ici je sais qu'il ya eu ça mais
je ne regarde pas l'information beaucoup
plus que ça parce que c'est ça je sais
ça me plombe s'implante vraiment
moralement si je suis trop aller coûte
de ça donc pour moi le futur de
l'humanité je les imagine de façon très
positive parce que je peux pas
l'envisager autrement sinon je me sens
trop mal donc
donc moi je les imagine forcément bien
mais je veux mais je veux pas trop le
jeu veut pas trop le formaliser dans ma
tête c'est une question des sources
d'information honnêtement ça va être
quelque chose dans la halle une d'un
journal que je vois dans le métro le un
truc que j'entends des gens qui
discutent
j'entends un truc à la radio ou sur
twitter ou sur facebook
ces masses est très limité je n'écoute
pas les informations auxquelles ils
avaient les informations du moins de
commentaires de péter dans le 20 heures
au genre de choses que l'actualité
l'actualité scientifique sage la suite
mais pas l'actualité pas l'actualité
courante genre l'élégie les jeunes tout
cela je suis parce que et quels sont tes
sources d'actualité scientifique du coup
ah bin là alors il faudrait que je joue
vraiment fini
parce que j'ai un moment un peu ça une
nappe qui a qui prend tous les essais
sismiques qui prend des liens rss et du
coup en fait je regarde pas trop les
sources je lis sans faire attention aux
sources
je vais te dire ça donc j'ai beaucoup de
trucs geek genre ars technica make up
the bridge wired genre de chose sinon
j'ai eurekalert futura-sciences nautilus
ce new scientist un trio pop sans bryant
encore scientific american techno
science and work and the news nature
universcience sur une chose ok du coup
tu as une appli qui liste des flux rss
de ces sites
non c'est moi qui en fait c'est une
appli de flux rss qui s'appelle feedly
et tu ajoutes les sources que que tu
veux à voir et à tous car regrouper
comme ça tu es avec lors d'un coup mais
c'est le seul ça fait beaucoup mais je
regarde de façon avec parcimonie
je suis pas accro à man à mon lecteur de
flux rss
aytus yeux ce qui se passe beaucoup dans
le monde scientifique république oui
puis non en fait je suis plus je suis
pas je suis pas trop dans l'actualité
moi je suis beaucoup plus danger un
sujet puis je vais voir ce qui s'est
fait dessus donc
je suis pas tant que ça l'actualité sans
que je regarde ce qui se passe
georges était au courant qu'il ya eu une
image du 1er au 9 mai mais je vais pas
être à fond sur toutes les nouvelles
publiées d'autant que je trouve que les
publications c'est bien mais faut pas
oublier qu'il ya besoin d'une
réplication il ya besoin de jeudi c'est
pas parce qu'on est au courant de
l'actualité scientifique on est au
courant de l'actualité de la science et
donc il ya ce biais là où moi j'ai
tendance à être un petit peu
influençable et je sais que si je vis un
truc après ça va me rester en tête et
donc il vaut mieux que je lisais un truc
où il ya un consensus scientifique qu'un
truc qui vient d'être découvert et cas
pas encore été répliquée qui a pas
encore consensus dessus ce genre de
choses ok tu penses que le rapport aux
effectifs des gens parlent beaucoup de
défis plus construire un rôle important
à jouer par de gaza scientifique
je pense qu'il ya un rôle important à
jouer la part de l'école c'est à l'école
que ça doit se faire c'est à l'école
qu'on doit apprendre à critiquer les
informations les informations doivent
viennent pourquoi est-ce que nous sommes
donné donc ici je pense que c'est
d'abord l'école car un rôle important à
jouer
la vulgarisation oui elle a un rôle à
jouer mais ils restent mineurs la
quantité de de gens qui font qu'ils sont
exposés au fip ou fake news par rapport
à la quantité de gens qui sont exposés à
de la vulgarisation est tellement
disproportionné que le rôle qu'on a à
jouer reste assez faible malheureusement
donc nous les gens les gens qu'on va
toucher avec notre vulgarisation ce sont
déjà des gens qui sont déjà intéressés
met donc en étant déjà intéressées ils
ont très probablement déjà cet esprit
critique et déjà cette chose qui fait
que leur fait news va peut-être qu'ils
n'ont pas complètement les croire donc
oui on a un rôle mais comparé à
l'éducation notre rôle est imminent quoi
et qu'est-ce que je peux faire
qu'est ce qui peut être fait au niveau
d'éducation tu pense se prend à ut1
cours sur bas alors je connais pas trop
le le système éducatif aujourd'hui mais
je pense que oui il ya un cours de deux
médias comment traiter les médias qui
doit être ajouté hmm hmm hmm aux
primaires honnêtement il y avait ces
gènes mental je crois qu'il a fait une
série de 2,3 vidéo où il allait dans une
classe est filmée comment est ce que une
prof enseigner aux gamins à faire la
part des choses et c'était passionnant
super intéressant et donc c'est un cours
qui je pense est fondamental parce que
nous quand on a grandi il y avait 2-3
médias il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas
grand chose donc ces médias là il avait
une certaine comme indien il y avait je
pense qu'il y avait beaucoup moins de
flics de fake news là dedans mais
maintenant qu'on a une multiplication
des médias que tout le monde peut
devenir un média la garantie qu'ils
aient une étude sérieuse qui a été fait
avant de publier l'information et les
moindres donc arriver à reconnaître
quelles sont les bonnes sources
d'information arrivé à savoir ok mais
c'est la personne qui publie c'est une
personne qui travaille pour telle
entreprise donc il ya des chances que je
suis en train de me faire manipuler ce
genre de chose c'est des choses qu'il
faut qu'il faut apprendre je pense dès
le primaire d'être fait partie du lait
sur devis de science nous ouais ouais
j'ai ma prochaine vidéo je la tourne de
plus en plus présente et en publie
dossier ouais donc bio science c1
c'est un organisme qui va publier des
vidéos sur youtube destinée aux profs
d'école aux enseignants qui sur des
sujets divers et variés et pour en fait
leur donner des clés de comment
enseigner certains certains thèmes
scientifiques
donc moi ce sera sur les volcans toi
aussi t'es pas normal et donc moi je
serai sur les volcans et donc ont donc
c'est ça donc c'est des vidéos vraiment
destiné aux profs
moi ça va être primaire mais il y en a
que ça va jusqu'au lycée je pense au
maximum inquiet parce que du coup cet
attentat sans avoir des trucs sur
peut-être l'esprit critique d'habitation
ce que je pensais
et que je laisse ça c'est pas c'est pas
un autre échelle mais mais c'est à
l'échelle de la main à la pâte
l'association qui qui fait ça et mais
oui mais je pense qu'il ya des déjà il
ya un truc qui est assez intéressant que
j'ai découvert en faisant billes de
science c'est qu'ils ont intégré quelque
chose qui je sais pas si ça existait à
notre époque mais qui s'appelle la
démarche d'investigation ou en fait ils
invitent les élèves en fait à créer leur
réflexion il ya et a trouvé comme un
trouver l'information en fait nul donc
on est déjà dans quelque chose qui
vraiment intéressant comme compétences à
développer par rapport au fait que news
mais après je pense qu un cours
spécifique aux médias
c'est ça va être nécessaire le problème
de faire un cours spécifique aux médias
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas grand
monde qui comprend les médias et donc
demandé aux profs qui sont souvent des
gens qui en minimum notre âge et donc
lions qui sont pas forcément très un
bilingue nouvelle technologie li-ion
c'est c'est difficile de leur demander
de faire un cours là dessus quand
eux-mêmes ne sont pas forcément formés
là dessus j'ai raison que ce pas parce
qu'aucun comprendre je te passe et a vu
la série de smart grid haye sur les
réseaux sociaux
oui j'ai vu ce que j'ai appris
énormément de choses en regardant ça et
si l'espace est meilleur que moi qui vit
son assiette de danse
il tue des arts et tout ça je m'en rends
pas compte de plein de choses qui se
passaient bien ça donc c'est un plus non
seulement donc les gens qui est lancée
n'y aurait il faudrait qu'ils soient
formés 1 2 il faudrait qu'on est une
source d'information fiable parce que ça
c'est c'est compliqué d'avoir cette
source d'information de comment
fonctionnent les médias de façon fiable
et 3 ça change tout le temps les règles
de youtube change tout le temps donc
genre y ait quelques mois je pense quand
tu faisais une vidéo d'eux
de 10 minutes ou plus ça t'a apporté
aucun avantage maintenant si tu fais une
vidéo 10 minutes ou plus tu peux
rajouter des pubs au québec à un site
très incitative à faire durer la vidéo
est ok qu'est ce que tu vas faire pour
dire faire durer la vidéo est donc tout
ça ça vient de ça ajoute vraiment des
des considérations qui sont difficiles à
prendre en compte
parce que ça bouge tout le temps qu'on
essaie ça c'est tellement complexe aussi
il faudrait des millions de
l'utilisateur des verbes il de contenu
ou pis le fait que facebook ait acheté
instagram que je crois qu'ils ont aussi
whatsapp tout ce genre de choses tu sais
que ok ben dans ce cas là ça veut dire
qu'une vidéo qui est sur instagram à va
pouvoir être promue sur facebook mais
pas sur youtube et vice versa bleu donc
à tout un tas de problématiques comme ça
qu'ils sont qui sont qui sont infinies
parce que ça change
honnêtement je pense que tous les mois
un changement c'est système très
complexe
voilà ça y est c'est qu'il faut vraiment
développe lupus de de rechercher outils
pour essayer de comprendre tout ça va
essayer de comprendre honnêtement je
pense aussi qu'il faudrait un petit peu
de législation mais le problème c'est
que les législateurs aussi c'est pas
forcément des férus technologies ag je
pense que c'est assez compliqué la fesci
à qui aurait les compétences pour
légiférer de bonne de la bonne manière
sûre ça c'est très très compliqué que
sont pas censés font pas légion ses
compétences et qu'il faut y ait plein de
données à analyser très compliqué et
puis on est en retard quoi on est très
très heureux parce qu'il ya plein de
données qu aurait pu être acquise depuis
un moment et qui n'ont pas été acquise
donc c'est je sais pas s'il ya des s'il
ya beaucoup de recherche qui se fait en
ce moment sur le sujet mais j'espère que
oui ouais mais pour après le problème il
y en a du coup qui permet l'analyse
twitter parce que tuteur et données sont
publiques
mais je situe bien loin de faire des
trucs aussi mais dans facebook
c'est compliqué facebook est passé à une
autre question j'essaie rapport à
l'éducation aux médias parce que si on
fait ça à l'école battant voit sa touche
et les élèves de l'école primaire et
tout ça il reste tout le reste de la
population
je pense que c'est trop tard poches
encore est-ce qu'on peut les attendre
franchement oui je pense que c'est trop
tard optimiste mais en fait c'est que
moi les gens à qui je parle ici c'est
des gens qui sont déjà intéressés
comment est ce que ta terre et gens qui
semblaient intéressés ok tu sais je veux
dire c'est si on me donnait des outils
jeter mais en fait il est là le problème
c'est que aujourd'hui on n'a pas
d'outils pour atteindre les gens qui
sont pas intéressés et d'un autre côté
les gens qui sont pas intéressés on va
pas les forcer non plus avoir du contenu
s'ils sont pas intéressés je veux dire
des gens qui ont des croyances qui
croient que je peins on est on y est
guidé par un jeu c'est des fourmis qui
nous contrôle georges n'importe quoi ils
ont pas envie d'entendre que c'est pas
vrai et est finalement est-ce que c'est
grave
alors ce débat sur cette question là des
fourmis peut-être que c'était si grave
sur d'autres questions laissées ça
exactement
et le problème c'est que c'est que après
tu déroule un fils quoi c'est ok mais
c'était pas grave pour les fourmis mais
est-ce que ça devient grave pour
l'homéopathie est ce que c'est grave de
ne pas être conscient que l'homéopathie
c'est un placebo mais était sûr et
compliqué allez c'est pas un oui ou un
non aussi clair que ça est-ce que c'est
grave 2
je veux pas trop donné notre désert
parce que je peux quand même faire taper
dessus mais met donc voilà donc c'est on
n'a pas accès à ces gens et ils ont ils
ont pas envie d'avoir accès à nous donc
on est dans un problème dans le serpent
qui se mord la queue donc ça veut dire
que soit c'est à nous de faire un effort
c'est à dire de d'aller chercher ces
gens là dans les domaines où ils sont
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui croit que on
est contrôlé par des fourmis
il va falloir faire une vidéo
expérimentale où on démontre qu'on n'est
pas contrôlée par des fourmis le
problème c'est que c'est difficile à
démontrer une croyance ça se sait
invalides difficilement mais mais ça
veut dire qu'il faut aller les chercher
donc ça veut dire qu'on rentre dans une
production de deux vidéos qui moi me
convient pas du tout ce sera c'est pas
moi qui ferai ce travail là où on est
obligé d'en fait d'aller être à l'écouté
des choses les plus farfelues quoi genre
les anti vaccins finalement je me
mouille un peu les uns les anti vaccins
et si tu veux pour pour arriver à faire
une vidéo de vulgarisation de pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faut vacciner son gamin ça
veut dire qu'il faut aller lire toute la
documentation contre les vaccins et est
arrivé à utiliser leurs arguments à eux
anti vaccins pour leur démontrer
pourquoi ces arguments anti vaccins ne
font pas le poids devant les arguments
pro vaccins et 7,7
donc ça oblige la personne a vraiment
aller se plonger dans un sujet de cette
news finalement pour essayer de ramener
les gens vers la vraie news
mais arriver à enlever l'idée une idée
dans la tête de quelqu'un c'est pas
juste avec une vidéo la c1 c'est un
travail de très très très très longue
haleine
donc très difficile donc c'est très
difficile c'est beau c'est beaucoup de
pain c'est beaucoup d'implication et
c'est beaucoup de n1 enfin un programme
intense et déjà je vois avec mon sac de
chips alors les sacs de chips
si j'ai la raison bah oui et après sur
les anti vaccin aussi sur d'autres
sujets thématiques et tout ça c'est
s'est passé c'est vraiment des sujets
très content surtout le changement
climatique saisir des sujets très
complexe et c'est tellement facile de
donner des mauvais bons arguments des
deux côtés et mexicains ont envie de
faire parce que finalement la raison
pour laquelle je crois que les papiers
vaccins ont en effet salvateur
c'est d'un côté il ya un argument un peu
un peu biologique les fonctionnements de
la chose et puis un autre côté a juste
c'est le consensus scientifique et
jeunes sachent que je suis prêt à
déférer mon jugement à dire que le
consensus scientifique a certainement
bien plus raison qu'une intuition de par
exemple de se faire mais après il ya
aussi le fait que moi ce que j'apprécie
dans la vulgarisation mais je suis pas
sûr que ce soit le cas de tous les gens
qui écoutent
c'est la nuance c'est à dire que de dire
que le mondial de dire que les vaccins
c'est bien ou c'est pas bien c'est pas
aussi noir ou blanc c'est pas vrai il ya
ya ya ces grilles en réalité il ya des
avantages il ya des inconvénients
il se trouve que le consensus
scientifique dit que les avantages prime
sur les inconvénients
après je connais pas assez le sujet pour
entrer plus en détail que ça parce que
moi aussi je défère mon jugement vers le
consensus scientifique surtout dans ce
cas là où les vaccins je ne suis pas
experte et je peux pas devenir expert du
jour en eux et je pense qu'on a un vrai
travail à faire nous en tant que
vulgarisateur le travail qu'on a à faire
c'est de d'aller chercher les experts
qui sont eux capables de d'avoir cette
nuance 2 1
et de deux de comprendre les arguments
des anti vaccins ou des antilles
changement climatique que tout ça de les
comprendre et d'expliquer pourquoi c'est
pas vrai avec pédagogie et nous de leur
donner la parole leur donner le staged
de leur donner peut-être un petit peu
plus de deux dimensions
comment dire parce qu'il ya plein
d'experts qui est un petit peu
difficultés à s'exprimer aussi est donc
de leur donner en fait cette cette voie
là mais c'est pas à nous en fait je veux
dire nous on n'a pas les compétences à
moins d'être expert un climat où experts
un vaccin en notre parole à nous on aura
toujours un poids beaucoup plus faible
que la parole d'un extrême après ça
devient un travail journalistique plus
que de vulgarisation c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué statut facebook c'est ok
bah je pense qu'on peut aller doucement
kéké paraît qu'il devient art question
quel est le message c'est que tu
aimerais que retiennent de cette
interview moi je sais pas franchement
j'en sais rien non mais parce que je
pense pas si tu veux en fait c'est
compliqué
comme pour répondre à cette question
c'est que dire qu'il ya un message clé
dans ce que j'ai dit ça veut dire que je
me place dans une position de deux
censeurs deux enseignants de tout ça et
j'ai pas j'ai pas envie de me placer
dans cette position là en fait j'ai
envie de me placer dans la position de
tu poses une question je te donne mon
avis est ici je te donne mon avis je dis
je ne suis pas en train de dire la
vérité je suis en train de donner mon
avis et je fais vraiment cette
distinction entre l'opinion il est fait
et quand je donne un fait là je dis
c'est quoi le message important
mais quand cette interview c'est une
succession d'opinion je peux pas te dire
quel est le message important parce que
c'était une opinion ou donc il ya des
opinions à moi qui vont certainement un
raisonner avec les auditeurs et d'autres
qui vont pas raisonner avec les
auditeurs et donc quand c'est une
opinion
je réserve mon jugement sur qu'est ce
qui était important parce que c'est une
opinion c'est pas un fait une opinion
que d'esprit que tu penses plus
importante factuel a une opinion et non
mais je veux pas faire voter non je
refuse je refuse cette question c'est
une opinion c'est pas un non non non
question refusé avec les patrons sur
cette question sinon va pour finir à ce
que tu pourrais faire de recommandations
de vidéos podcasts livres personnes à
suivre alors un vidéo qui sait que je
pourrai recommandé en vidéo donc vidéo
scientifique en france est forcément ou
pas forcément ce que tu veux ok alors je
recommanderais sabrina cruz qui est une
new buzz canadienne j'aime beaucoup ce
café et qui sait que je recommanderais
d'autres sciences dures qui soit pas
déjà ultra connus d'ici pense c'est vrai
que j'ai découvert très récemment j'ai
trouvé ça génial
ouais non mais elle est vraiment bien je
l'aï rencontré à un événement aux
états-unis - après mon nom mon dieu mon
inspiration c'est ce master idée c'est
vraiment lui qui est un qui m'a vraiment
inspirée à faire des vidéos
donc c'est forcément lui moi qui à qui
je pense en premier
donc on va dire ça brille la cruze et ce
matériel et en podcast est ce que
j'écoute en podcast via radio l'a
toujours l'éternel qui est vraiment bien
sinon étonnamment ge dans mes
consommations je consomme moins de
vulgarisation scientifique que ce qu'on
croit je consomme beaucoup de choses sur
le sport ce genre de choses donc en
sciences finalement je suis pas tant pas
ton coin d'un sourd
ah oui j'ai fait une j'ai fait une
interview récemment à rfi au tour de la
question et j'ai découvert l'émission
par la même occasion et donc je vous
conseille rfi autour de la question
j'avais j'ai trouvé ça super intéressant
entre les invite des gens est en fait tu
lui poses
plein de questions et souvent c'est très
intéressant donc donc la tête apparaît
que de moi ma vie mon oeuvre
globalement les éternels des interviews
du livre aussi pas mal
voilà bah merci à toi d'avoir accepté
d'être interviewé et puis merci aux
éditeurs d'avoir écouté conseillé à
faire des trucs classiques et laqué
commenter et à bientôt probablement